welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video are
breaking down Aquaman in the lost
[Music]
kingdom the dceu is now at an end and we
have a lot to talk about throughout this
video we're going to be going over what
happens in the movie The Drama behind
the scenes the future of the DC you and
a lot more though this movie is
predicted to sink at the box office I
think some things can be salvaged and
perhaps this isn't Jason M's final
voyage at DC so come with us as we
plunder the plot but be warned me
hearties there are spoilers ahead you're
not even a pirate but please hit the
thumbs up if you enjoy and make sure you
subscribe for videos like this every day
the way huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into Aquaman
2 4 years ago I was basically
unemployed a Wanderer with no
home but now I'm a husband and a
father and I wouldn't have it any other
way and how you do pops my job was a
little less stressful than yours okay so
I'll be talking about what happened
behind the scenes as we go through the
movie but I mainly want to focus on the
plot first however some of the stuff's
difficult to avoid and it's kind of
crazy what's been going on Aquaman 2
picks up in the aftermath of the first
film with Arthur Curry ruling over
Atlantis however he walks Between Two
Worlds and on the surface is raising a
family this is along with his wife
redacted who you can tell they cut out
as much as possible now Amber herd is
very much the elephant in the room with
her highly publicized trials getting
lots of attention that was of course
against ex-husband Johnny Deb with
everything being AED out in public
though I'm not going to get into that
side of things one of the key Witnesses
in it was Walter h
and in case you don't know he was in
charge of DC under he talked about her
trolling death as she' stated she'd been
turning up on set with his script Pages
becoming less and less however Hamada
stated this wasn't due to the headlines
with Depp and that they were actually
planning on recasting without that in
mind stated sh Mamoa had a little
chemistry on S and they saved that first
movie purely in the editing suite and
there was also that big petition online
that gained millions of signatures to
have her removed and it's clear the
studio started weighing up the options
however it was then reported that Elon
Musk contacted the company and
threatened to go scorched Earth if she
was cut from the sequel there was also a
report recently that came up with her
therapist notes which said she'd felt
tormented by mimo on set he apparently
showed up drunk and dressed like Johnny
Deb which to be fair his reps
immediately denied people pointed out
he's always dressed like that but it's
clear there's definitely been tensions
off screen now why I'm telling you this
is to talk about the direction of the
film which was likely impacted by all
these issues thus they've taken the
focus away from Arthur and miror and
made a buddy up brother team up in
Arthur and or whether that was always a
direction they'd go we we don't know but
it leads into what an adventure that's
all about family their mother Arthur son
and father they all play a big role with
black man are still wanting to avenge
his father too now earlier in the a
James ju told Empire he was pulling from
some retro horror to inspire the film's
look this was mainly the 60s movie
Planet of the vampire which visually
this film borrows a lot from there's
green and black a wild vibrancy of
colors and lots of things going on
visually that make the movie pop as I
mentioned it picks up in the aftermath
of the first film in which we saw Black
Manta a drift in the sea picked up by
sailor as he was nursed back by Dr
Steven Shin an Atlantis obsessive played
by Jim from the office the movie sees
Manta wanting to avenge his father and
we see his shin and his expedition une
Earth and ancient evil the film opens up
with basically the Montage from Thor of
and Thunder with Aquaman going through
what his life's been like you get lots
of flashes to the first movie and see
him at home being a parent that swigs
Guinness with his dad and also has to
deal with the Atlantis Council it
continues the family Motif though
without even being brought across to the
villain sh uncovers the lost kingdom
which is known as necris which was led
by an ancient evil that was named cordax
cordax was Alan's brother and he used a
mineral called oracol kulum to further
his Industries and build up his kingdom
however this was extremely toxic and I
poisoned the oceans along with the
surface atan went to him and was like
just stop F I get probably get in
trouble for that H but after a big fight
they put a curse on the kingdom which
was then sealed in his blood now that
kind of shows a disagreement between
Brothers is of course carried across to
or and Arthur who are going to have to
write the wrongs of the past now that
man discovers a big monster cave man
still decides to go in it like yeah
we're just going to go in and it's here
he comes across the black Trident
grabbing it he's somewhat possessed by
cordax and he leads him to the location
of the mcau culin a 5 months pass and we
learn that temperatures on the Earth are
heating up and that there's been a
plague which has swept through Atlantis
we learn the Oracle culum emits
greenhouse gases and there is lots of
talk about global warming in the movie
the planet's heating up Arthur's rules
Rocky and even William defo vco gets
pooched off screen when one of mantis's
culen raids leads into him attacking
Atlantis we then start to see how
powerful he's become Mira gets injured
and it becomes Amber her in the Lost
character and th along with his friendly
octopus tofo AU heads to rescue his
brother now script wise the whole thing
is a bit cliche and it's I don't think
it's going to win any awards for writing
however where I think the film really
Exiles it's in all its locations and
unique characters as Arthur tries to
track down Manta we go to some brilliant
places and meet lots of unique and
interesting creatures the kingfish is
like a jab the Hut style gangster that
leads Orman Arthur to a place known as
Devil's steep this is a vast jungle
filled with giant grasshoppers and a
mechanical almost Resident Evil four
style Island at the heart of it all this
keeps the movie interesting and engaging
with one really getting to flex his
horror muscles as well now I do think
recently the DCU went a bit too much on
the demon behind the scenes thing
controlling it all and this has been
seen in a number of different films the
first Shazam did it Black Adam did it
too and these are used as a way to
empower the villains still though Sauron
sorry cordax is easily the best one and
I think that's down how good one is with
horror to be fair sber is too and yet
it's nice to see elements like this in
the film who really steals the show
though is Patrick Wilson with him
becoming the MVP of the entire movie for
me mangoes on a great Arc will get into
in just a bit and his back and forth
with Arthur really makes the movie sore
now after things go hay at devil's
breath we learn a bit more about the
curse on cordax this was something that
was sealed with blood and thus only the
descendants of atlan are able to lift it
this puts Arthur's newon in the
crosshairs and Arthur rushes home to
find it destroyed although the trailers
made it look like man to kill Tommy they
managed to save him by putting him on
life support I was kind of thinking it
might be a dad for a dad but in the end
they don't go that route however what
they do is Storm necris where Manta is
about to sacrifice Junior Shin ends up
saving him and Mir is able to grab the
kid but at this point Manta throws the
Trident caught by or he then becomes
possessed with the Allure of the throne
becoming too much you have to remember
he's pretty much like cordax was and
that he should have been the ruler but
was cast out by his brother thus him and
Arthur end up having a fight but
Arthur's managed to do the old the old
you know the one look inside you dig
deep that sort of thing now that kind of
stuff it can be really cliche actually
do something great and build off the
first film that's so Arthur below the
arena saying how he would have liked to
have been a brother to him too that line
gets played up here again and I thought
it was a really good way to play off
their first meeting unfortunately though
Arthur smacked off the Altar and his
blood spills which unleashes cordex
still though he manages to destroy him
in the tridon in one Blow by throwing
his through the Cent of cordax is it's a
cordax moment and in the end the planet
is saved with Atlanta deciding to reveal
itself to the world I'm sorry guys now
it's kind of like when wakanda did it
and Aquaman even Ends by saying I am
Aquaman still a bit like Marvel app but
still though it brings a message that we
should all work together which is very
much what the movie's about or is given
another chance and they go with a story
he died in the Battle and man gets to go
out and just experience the world guy
was pretty much he was a bit of a racist
to be fair that first movie he hated
everyone in the surface world I know
that word's a bit strong but he just
didn't like us and even earlier in the
movie author was saying look mate your
Prejudice it's holding you back so this
chance he gets to go out and see the
world and finally embrace all the
different cultures and that kind of
takes us into the post credit scene
which builds off the back of a J from
earlier in the movie in it we see or
eating a delicious delicious burger that
ties back to the line from the movie in
which M said he never tried one this is
because there's no burgers in Atlantis
and and he also stuffs a little
cockroach in cuz that was set up earlier
too and yeah that's it so the final
final scene of the DC euu of all time is
or eating a burger now the people who've
seen this as you can guess it's DC the
DC fans no one hates DC more than DC
fans they're in a bloody uproar and I
think as well it's kind of disappointing
the DCU goes out on a lame joke kind of
sums up how it was run though but I was
kind of surprised at how they decided to
go with it I actually thought they might
close out with something thanking the
fans for the past 10 years you know cuz
Man of Steel was released in 2013 and
for everyone who's stuck with the
universe for the last decade I thought
that we might get something a bit more
endgame closes out with a cast names all
on a big thing with all the actor
signatures a silhouette and clips from
their appearances for this it's kind of
weird and at the very least I was
expecting some kind of acknowledgement
The Flash was originally supposed to be
the final film in the DCU but release
dates got moved about so maybe that
should be seen more is a celebration
whereas this one's kind of just a sort
of Standalone film now in the end though
this is how we've got it and it kind of
reminds me a bit of the poem The Hollow
Men by TS Elliott in case you don't know
what that is yet just just as a
reference it closes out with the
following lines this is the way the
world ends this is the way the world
ends this is the way the world ends not
with a bang but a wimper and that's kind
of what I feel about the way the DC EU
was ended as it closes out with a wimper
instead of a Big Bang it's sad now there
were also other scenes that were
supposed to appear in the movie
involving two different versions of
Batman that were basically shrouding as
bat that's because the release date of
this changed which also meant the Batman
in the movie was a different actor now
in one version of the movie we had Ben
afflac returning which was leaked due to
his name being spotted on a Warner
Brothers tour once the news got out
Jason Mamo embraced the publicity and
posted an image of him and Ben together
this was going to tease the return of
the actor and he was going to come back
as Batman in some form or another sort
of like the way they ended Black Adam by
teasing Henry caval and it was clear
there were plans to bring the SN verse
back however they also shot one
involving Michael Keaton which was going
to TI to the Flash's original ending in
case you don't know that movie was
supposed to culminate with keep balls
stepping out the limo and then Supergirl
arriving on the scene in the end they
changed this to Clooney so once again
they could end it on a joke the Aquaman
teas was then shot to explain why this
film was still connected to it so we're
not wondering why he wasn't wiped out
during the flash if anyone cares it's
it's lots of timey why me wibbly wobbly
stuff however the exx said they didn't
want to tease the universe that might
not be coming and thus both versions of
the film had their Batman scenes removed
when I say both versions yet just to
clarify I mean one had Affleck in it and
the other version had Katon either way
we know that people like Blue Beetle are
said to be the first hero in the DCU but
Superman's the first movie in the DCU
yeah it's a bit weird but either way
that's how they've kept things like the
post credit scenes still in that movie
in all honesty I feel like they know
they messed up by announcing that none
of these films really matter and I don't
know why they didn't hold off until 2024
there was no need to shout out these
were all getting scrapped before the
films released and with Superman
dropping in 2025 at the earliest I feel
they could have held off until then it's
clear though they've lost all their
faith in this stuff and the studio
didn't even have a red carpet Premiere
the sequel to a billion doll superhero
movie not getting that that is kind of
wild to me and it's crazy how much the
landscape's changed in the last year
personally I think it's just a case of
oversaturation as we've had so many
middling superhero movies at this point
that more often than not you're going to
be disappointed so in some ways people
just seem to be switched off and that's
abundant in the dc2 which sucks cuz I do
genuinely wish this film the best I kind
of feel in general that comic book
movies have become like comic books
themselves in which even the Avid
readers aren't that interested in
picking up all the spin-off stuff now
what I mean by that is like look I'm a
massive reader got loads of graphic
novels but when I go to the comic shop I
don't pick up every single issue out
there what I tend to pick up is the
stuff I'm interested in and that's also
what I tend to read and just keep
picking up now when there's a massive
crossover event involving a lot of
characters I'll pick up every book from
that for example I've got all this stuff
from Civil War but I don't necessarily
think I'd pick up all those characters
if they weren't connected to that story
that's kind of what I feel like with
these shed universes too and stuff you
wouldn't check out you ended up doing it
because it was all connected to that
story now though these universes that
story pulling them together it just
isn't there and though people go see the
big stuff they're not there for every
single film and TV show so yeah that's
kind of how I view the market I know
there's hundreds of factors involved in
why these movies aren't performing well
um and I am praying that you know that
that first movie for example that didn't
have a great opening weekend but over
time it built an audience and yeah go
see it if you're interested in superhero
films
either way that's how he CLS out the DCU
with it not teasing anything at all and
just being a full stop now as for my
thoughts on the movie it's kind of a
weird one as I realized when I was in
the cinema that this was going to be the
last time that I watched the DCU film in
the theaters it's been 10 been 10 years
since I kickstarted with Man of Steel
and I've spent a third of my life
following this franchise it's kind of
sad that it's gone out like this as I
think had this been released before
Black Adam Shazam and the Flash the
conversation around it would be a bit
different
the script is a bit all over the place
and you can spot the re-shoot a mile
away but at its core I think it's an
enjoyable film I think the horror
elements work really well and there's a
real sense of wonder to what happens
throughout I know the CGI is getting
criticized as being a bit flat but
compared to the green screening in
Quantum Mania it it slaps am modok's
cheeks completely with both hands M MOA
is just having a blast and when he's
going back and forth with or it really
works to the point I would have loved to
have seen something with them later down
the line at this point though the
writing it is on the wall all of the
main three though feel like they've
really evolved past the first film and
Manta even builds off that too loved
seeing him at the end refus to take
Arthur's hand and it brings things full
circle from when he let his dad die in
the first movie still though I don't
think this would have been enough to say
the DCU and like all movies you know it
is imp perfect you kind of don't know
where things are going at point and
characters do make very strange logic
choices also that invisible costume that
he doesn't wear over his head turns
invisible just stuff like that it's a
nitpicky but yeah it it just kind of
dings the movie a bit there's also some
plots that have clearly been cut down
with stuff like the council that gets
brushed to the side the global warming
thing keeps popping up but it's never
really a main thing and sort of feels
like an afterthought also they did my
man William defo dirty and I doubt he's
going to be William def friend to the
Warner Brothers in the future cuz worst
thing is they killed the guy and didn't
even warn a brother still though I
enjoyed this way more than I thought I
would and and I think that it's better
than the first film that had that
Pitbull song which killed it for me but
I like that and this was a nice Step
Beyond it obviously the social media and
Bargo lifting the day the movie releases
as well that's a bit weird and I know
lots of people had saw it and then were
asked to not talk about it online there
were rumors that this test did a lot of
them back here as well and we all know
what happened with that too so there was
this weird embargo that made people
think it was absolutely terrible but in
all honesty it's better the most
superhero movies that we've had recently
sure not all the jokes land but Arthur
and M get a great Arc and Visually it's
hard to deny it's striking so in the end
th said the whole thing's over I'm ready
to let go and see where we go next
unfortunately the dceu will always feel
like wasted potential to me but I can
take solace in the fact we got Snider's
Trilogy at least and some solid movies
along the way I will talk about where
things are going to go just a bit but as
for now this gets a s out of 10 I'm nice
like that now if you enjoy the content
and want to help support us we're
currently selling some all connected
shirts he's massively helped to pay the
bills and it also means you get some
cool merch to rock we also have a
membership program that you can sign up
to by clicking the join button and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos now as for the future of DC we
know James gun's currently working on
his upcoming film title Superman Legacy
the cast is stacked and things are
really ramping up with a kickstarting
his first phase title Gods and Monsters
you may have also seen reports that
Warner Brothers are in trouble
financially and thus it seems like the
focus is solely on that though they have
other the films announced I don't
actually think Productions on them
started yet and thus I think they're
going to see if Superman's a success
first and then roll into the others
shortly after that perhaps they'll get
the dailies back and go from there but I
think they're probably holding off for a
while to see how things go all the DC
films this year have underperformed and
from a business point of view that makes
the most sense normally when you get
these universes they put the C before
the horse and start making films before
they even know if that first one's a hit
so I think being patient is a smart
thing to do especially with all the
financial pressure resting on gun's
shoulders in the meantime we have
sequels to the Batman and Joker so it's
not like we're going to be star for DC
content there's also the penguin show
and Matt reev zham one which has said to
be part of the DCU Creature Commandos is
coming as well with Superman Legacy
being a big kickoff point so they can
really wait to see how that performs and
then decide if they want to BET The
House on Gun there's also rumors that
they could be merging with Paramount and
who knows how the landscape of the
studio is going to look in 5 years
either way though it seems fine on the
surface it's clear behind the scenes
that there's been a lot of pressure I
think gun could definitely pull it off
though and so far he's made a great DC
movie a great DC series and obviously a
great Trilogy at Marvel Studios now in
the run up to this Jason M also said
when it comes to Aquaman it's not
looking good in an interview with ET he
said sorry entertainment tonight when I
say he's interviewing ET but not him
this
is likely I think your last time playing
Aquaman you know I don't necessarily
want it to be the end right yeah so I
don't think it's really like a it was a
choice I think obviously the whole you
know James and Peter and DC wanting to
start the new thing up so I I don't know
if it will be because the truth of it is
I mean I guess if the audience loves it
but right now I'm
like it's not not looking too good now
earlier in the a when s were making
public statements about their DC future
you might remember Mamoa did one too he
said that he'd spoken to gun about
making his dream project and seemed to
be ecstatic that that was going down now
because of this many have suspected
he'll return for the DCU but he'll be
playing someone DC
new that is lobo and in the same
interview with ET they went into it and
teased it the
DCU is effectively ending what
conversations have there's rumor there's
things going around have you and James
had the discussion
about what happens you being a part of
the DC Universe again in the future I
know James Gunn is definitely a fan
Peter saffron's obviously very close to
if there's a place in their world for me
I would love to be a part of it having
said that you know i' like it this
character's been me for 12 years so it's
really comes down to I think they're
really amazing men and if if there's
something that uh the fans love I'm sure
they would honor honor but I definitely
think there's I'll be this is my home
Warner a DC is definitely my home so
that's all I'll say yeah
there's I read I
read and I saw that Lobo cover and I was
like
well look at the guy look at the guy I
was a big Lobo fan growing up so I've
have every comic so that would be really
cool that would be cool so you're
telling me right this guy isn't Lobo
after those comments and the dream
project one it's OB it's obvious mate
it's bloody obvious and yeah I'd love to
see him in that role too in case you
don't know Lobo is Bounty and air and he
travels the Stars cracking up Bas dishes
guy's got a cool bike is super strong
and powerful and would be the kind of
character guns already Adept out writing
lowo already had a really interesting
Arc and when he first came out he was
seen as a villain man was arrogant and
self centered and the last of his kind
after wiping them out for fun still
though we watched him develop as a
character and change his ways which
would be something cool that they could
do in the films there's lots of ways I
think they could take him and once the
fan art starts you know that's it I
think if this film flops it won't be
down to him either and with him saying
DC's his home I'd love to see him back
again I don't think he can be blamed if
this flops and I think at the moment
there's just a lack of interest in
movies in general everything's kind of
been done and we've seen lots of Bombs
over the last year you've kind of hit a
point where almost every comic book
movie's been done and we've got way more
content than what we've ever had before
so people are more selective over what
they watch with comic book movies not
being the guaranteed success that they
once were still though I wish Mama all
the best and he genuinely seems like a
really cool dude guy's been going around
doing the press and giving back to fans
so I hope we see him return in some form
or
another I think I know someone in my
build to help
us you look
rough the job little brother high five
do not call me
brother I cannot believe you let this
happen yeah well I hate this job true
king builds Bridges
right true king builds
Bridges anyway that wraps up the video
and huge thank you for checking it out
please drop a like and leave your
comments below as there's more here to
talk about than just the movie story
lots of things going on lot lots of
things in the future and yeah I'd love
to hear you guys thoughts so make sure
you drop them below now if you want some
else to watch we've got a video on
screen right now where we talk about all
the stuff going on with Jonathan majes
did that with mt it was a great little
conversation and yeah definitely head
over there right after this by the way
huge thank you for sing through the
video I've been your host Paul you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care
peace